alright welcome everyone to this brief
webinar on the HTTPS protocol and some
changes coming to ncbi web services my
name is Eric Sarah's I'll be talking to
you for a few minutes today about what
these changes are and what you can
expect and what you should do I'm here
with my colleague Peter Cooper who will
be monitoring the questions during the
webinar and we'll try to get to as many
of them as we can so what we're going to
be talking about today are some upcoming
changes to the way that ncbi receives
web service requests and this primarily
has to do with a protocol called HTTPS
which is essentially secure HTTP it's
something that has been around for some
time and is becoming more popular for a
variety of reasons we'll talk a little
bit about what some of those are so
we're going to try and do this afternoon
is talk about why we're doing this
because we have to this is a federal
mandate for all websites maintained by
the federal government some of the
benefits that we get from using HTTPS
and then what's actually happening at
NCI in particular and what would be the
consequences for you or your users
customers that are using software
products that you're making etc and
perhaps most interesting to you what
should you do now what do you need to do
to respond to these changes what can you
expect in the future and then some
details so I'm going to talk very
generally about this I'm not going to
get into a lot of technical detail we're
going to have some additional web pages
that will be going up very soon
hopefully this week that will describe
more of the detail that you might need
to be aware of and i'll give you of
course some contact information at the
end if you do have additional questions
that you can get in touch with us so the
reason why we're doing this is because
we were told to by the Office of
Management and Budget this is a federal
office that controls a variety of things
but does supervise the web presence of
the federal government you can find out
more about this going to https CIA gov
at the top of this page
it talks to you about the https only
standard that has now been rolled out
throughout the federal government and
this was a announcement that was made
actually about a year ago in jun 2 2015
that all federal agencies must make all
of their current existing websites and
services available and accessible
through https only protocols by the end
of this calendar year by December 31st
and 2016 so that's the challenge that's
the mandate that we have and so that is
the reason why these changes are coming
about and just FYI of course this means
that any other government website that
you're dealing with is going to have to
do these same changes as well so it
certainly is not limited to NCBI or NLM
or NIH or anything like that why are we
doing this why is the government of many
many other private enterprise of
switching to https well for a large
number of reasons only a few of which
I've outlined here HTTPS encrypts all of
the web traffic between the server and
clients so you now have a encrypted
transfer of information which gives you
heightened privacy and security so using
HTTPS provides not just privacy and
security but a consistent level of
privacy and security across all federal
websites all of the the data that is
transferred during these transactions
maintains its own privacy and it
prevents various kinds of attacks so it
protects it prevents for example unknown
websites or web sites that are trying to
hack in to various sites from
masquerading as federal site so it's
protects the public from other sites
that are trying to pretend that they
might be in CBI or in a limb it also
prevents the injection of malware into
web traffic so if someone was to
intercept web traffic between the server
and the client then they could in under
HTTP inject code potentially into that
traffic and the user wouldn't be aware
of that and that malware would then
appear to have come from the trusted
site that they're trying to get
information from this is an obvious
problem
and HTTPS does eliminate many of those
kinds of concerns there's a variety of
other reasons that you might explore on
the web about HTTPS but those are a
couple of view of the ones that make the
most impact so what's happening at NCBI
there's a couple of things so in
September at the end of sep tember if
you have a get or head request now I'll
talk a little bit about what those are
in a minute those are going to be
redirected to https if they come over
HTTP so an example there is if you load
a pubmed article over HTTP after
September 30th that URL will be
automatically redirected to HTTPS and
then the same URL so the protocol will
be switched automatically for you so if
you are accessing NCBI using a web
browser you should really don't have to
do much at all this will happen
automatically what you might see a
variety of these little icons there's a
green lock icon in some browsers other
icons that indicate to the user that
you're now over a secure transaction or
secure session HTTPS but that's
essentially all that you probably would
notice so not much has to be done if
you're simply accessing NCBI over the
web many API requests also will not have
problems with this if they are simply
providing get requests or head requests
which basically means a URL so you're
using the utilities or something like
that and it's simply a URL that you're
posting that will automatically get
redirected to https also but if you are
using HTTP POST and you're providing a
request and these are mainly again for
API users like the e-utilities those
will be rejected after September 30th
with a status 403 they simply cannot be
converted to https if they're submitted
over HTTP so if you have processes that
are submitting requests using HTTP POST
it's a problem and it needs to be
changed so that those can be done over
HTTPS that's one of the major things
that we see is a as a potential
problem for developers and users out
there so that's one to be aware of so
the consequences if you're only using a
web browser again you probably don't
need to do anything right so or if you
have clients that are simply using or
accessing NCBI web pages over browsers
it's not a big deal this will
automatically redirect but I would
recommend if you link to us if you have
web pages that do have links to ncbi
change them to https links right in your
HTML code it's just better practice and
that way there's an every direction that
needs to happen but it's not a
requirement if you have HTTP links
they'll be redirected for you most web
browsers again will handle these 301
redirects elegantly and it's not a
problem if you are using an API so these
are the e-utilities could be the blast
URL API any other API that ncbi provides
your request may fail after September
30th and in general it's going to be
hard for us to predict all different
kinds of failures that may happen it
depends a lot on how you have set up
your API calls but we know that if
you're using HTTP POST you will have
problems so again as I said that's the
thing to worry most about it's possible
that the mechanisms that you're using to
call the api's may not handle 301
redirects properly so the best thing to
do is not even risk the redirects but
just change the protocol which we'll
talk about in just a moment but those
are the things to be most concerned
about so what should you do change the
protocol all right so if you are
accessing any NCBI website Rini NCBI
service or any API calls NCBI over HTTP
change the code protocol to HTTPS and
all you have to do is just replace HTTP
with HTTPS that's it right all of the
other parts of the URL stay the same you
should know that all web services right
our web services on online pubmed blast
all of the sequence databases all of
entre all of
web pages as well as all of our AP is
the e-utilities blaster API everything
works over HTTPS today so there's no
reason you can't change in five minutes
just do it now all right so everything
works there shouldn't be a problem and
just switch it immediately and start to
use HTTPS now we understand that that is
not possible for everyone it's going to
take some time to update code code bases
other kinds of software packages that
might be out there that's why we're
trying to get the word out as quickly as
we can before the September 30th
deadline now you might be asking
yourself what if Y September 30th versus
December 31st the federal deadline is is
December 31st in lms internal deadline
in September 30th so we're trying to get
this done early so that we can fix
problems before the federal mandate
takes effect so one thing that you can
do if it's not possible to change all of
your code before that time or you're not
sure how much of a problem you might be
in we have set up some test servers so
I've put the URLs to these test servers
on the screen these are currently live
and you can direct traffic over HTTP to
these servers and test your code so if
you get a return from these servers
you're okay right so your your code is
handed to redirect properly that's not
to say that you should not change to
https these redirection servers will not
be up there indefinitely these are a
crutch essentially to help you test now
and they will be going away at the end
of the calendar year when we cannot
accept HTTP requests anymore so but
these are things that you can use now to
see how things work so if you are
accessing a web page for example you can
use the first one over HTTP colon slash
slash https ncbi nlm nih gov so then any
other URL that you would normally have
as going to ww NCBI you can now go to
https NCBI and test if you're accessing
the e-utilities right there's HTTP EU
tills reader
rec'd right so simply place that URL
instead of EU toast at NCBI and then
your normal URL and if that works you're
in good shape all right blast redirect
that's for the blast URL API so those
are three test servers that are alive
right now and you can begin testing so
I'd highly recommend that you try those
out if you have any questions about
whether or not your code might work or
not so those are two things change it if
you can change it as quickly as you can
to https everything search your place
just get it done if you have questions
try these test servers and see what's
going on now very soon we are going to
be releasing some more details about
this that will be available on the web
i'm going to show you what these pages
will look like hopefully they're going
to go live this week and then you'll be
able to look at them directly there is a
page that will provide full guidance the
link to that page is at the top of the
screen it's not live yet but it will be
there's also a developed page and an API
page that are currently live on our site
they're going to be updated with links
to that new page giving you all of those
guidance details so i'm going to show
you what those pages are now but before
I leave this slide I just want to again
emphasize that we're we're here to help
if you have questions about this if
you're concerned about this right to
info at NCBI please describe as much as
you can what your situation is and will
try to give you some good advice about
how you can proceed to accommodate these
changes so on the NCBI homepage there is
a develop link I've circled it here in
red that is a page that we have designed
particularly for developers people who
are using our API sore toolkits to build
software it's a really good page know
about if you don't know about it
hopefully you do now it's a good page to
advertise to friends and colleagues you
want to keep track of what's going on at
NCBI regarding toolkits api's etc
clicking that link when the new pages go
out again I'll emphasize these are not
live right now
these will be coming live there's going
to be a link you can see it up on the
upper right ncbi goes https only
starting September 30th get more details
you click that thing it's going to take
you to this page that has all of the
details on it also on this developed
page and on the live version of this
page there is a link to API so there's a
separate API page it has details about
various of our AP is it also has the
same ad over here it will have that ad
which will get you to this page so I'll
show you that new page now and again
most of what's on this page I've already
told you so there's not a great deal of
information here except some links a
little bit more discussion but the
bottom line stuff that we've already
talked about is essentially what this
page is trying to show a couple of
things on the page we have tried to be
in contact with a variety of services
bio Java biopython bioperl etc many of
these organizations already are aware
that these changes are occurring many of
these libraries are already working fine
but you can track those issues there
we're continuing to try and be aware of
other communities that need to update
their code https again please contact us
if you have questions about this or or
other information that you'd like us to
be aware of if you keep scrolling down
on this page there's a few other points
I just wanted to highlight and again
you've got this information and the
PowerPoint slides you can take that and
take a look at it again after September
30th everything is going to either be
redirected or rejected so it's either
going to be redirected to HTTPS or it's
going to be an error condition so those
HTTP POST request for example are going
to get 403 forbidden all right so that's
a real issue so please be aware of that
again check your API stuff just check it
it needs to be tested so that you make
sure that it's actually going to work
after the redirection and after the
HTTPS only world that we're going to be
in in 2017 so when you look down here
again these test servers are detailed
and discussed in the little table there
I've already told you about those so
there's not a lot of new information
there but those are set
up for your benefit all right so that's
basically what I have to say so do the
tests do the changes please let us know
if you have questions about it or any
other concerns so I'll be quiet at the
moment let peter know let the question
pod know if you do have questions about
this and we'll we'll discuss okay are we
have a answered many of them by typing
there's a couple that I didn't answer
I'm not sure I completely understand
some of them one of them is you want to
know if the test servers will internally
switch them over to https I'm not quite
sure what that means maybe you have a
better idea what that means so what the
test servers do and you can you can try
this out just in a web browser is they
simply do the redirection for you all
right and so it simulates what will
happen after September 30th so I'm not
exactly sure precisely what you might be
my internal redirection but if you mean
internal to ncbi yes so the HTTP request
will come in to us we will redirect that
to an HTTPS equivalent and send that
response back to you so if your code is
not able to handle the redirect that
will fail if you are able to handle and
see and handle that redirect then it'll
be fine right now there are no redirects
happening so you can submit HTTP
requests to the EU tools and blast and
they'll function normally they'll just
come back to you as standard status to
hundreds but 1 sep tember 30th happens
that will no longer be the case you'll
be redirected and so to simulate that
redirect point something towards those
test servers and you'll you'll get the
same 301 redirect that will happen after
September 30th here we have another
question about proxy servers that
automatically change the URL we are
looking into some of these now my best
advice is to do the testing so if you
have a proxy server try and submit those
requests to these test servers and see
what happens and let us know if there
are challenges that you have with that
or if you're not getting things to work
we have already been in contact with
easy proxy those discussions are
going right now we should be able to get
something worked out where you'll have
appropriate certificates set up for easy
proxy to work if that's something or
other proxy services like that are
concerns for you please let us know and
we'll give you some additional guidance
okay we have one more thing and I'm not
sure we can really address this in the
webinar but I just will put it out there
so somebody has requested that they they
wondered if it's possible for us to
extend our deadline since the federal
mandate is December because they have
software and they can change their code
but the customer support might not get
it out to the people in time and I don't
know if we have any if we can comment on
that or not but i'll let you decide on
that one so if you read this document
that i have up there on the screen there
is a little part of it that talks about
how after September 30th we may open up
some some blackout periods or something
like that where we'll stop doing the
redirect for a little temporary time
period and we will publicize what those
time periods will be we realize that
folks that are trying to change software
this is a challenge it's a little bit of
tight timing we appreciate that part of
the reason for the sep tember 30th is
just to make sure that everyone is aware
that problems exist so if you know that
there's going to be a problem you can
try and get it changed before december
31st so if you have software that really
looks like you're not going to be able
to change it before the end of the year
please let us know we'll try and work
with you we do plan to have some open
windows between you know in october
through december where we might relax
the redirect from time to time all right
just to make sure that people can
confirm that things are working so if
you do have concerns let us know we
can't help you if we don't know but if
you do let us know we'll try and work
with you to see what we can do Eric I
was paying attention to the question pod
so this page that you showed is there a
URL to this that was out a link on one
of the slides the one here at the end
yes there is a URL let me go back up in
the slides here somebody has to see that
again so on this
lied and again this will be something
that will be available to you it's
available on the ftp site now from the
materials link the top URL is the URL to
that page again it's not live right now
but hopefully this week it should be up
sowww slash home slash developed / https
hyphen guidance dot s HTML so that's
where it should be you guys are getting
a little bit of advance warning today
with the webinar so i tried to copy most
of that page onto the powerpoint so at
least you can get a sense of what you're
going to be safe there can you show the
NCBI homepage and just sort of how to
get to the webinars and courses page
because I think a lot of people want
these slides and although we had the
link at the beginning it might be a
little difficult to get that so we just
show them how to navigate they'll be in
the arc in the archive section by
tomorrow in the NCBI homepage go to
learn which is over here on the right
then on the learn page scroll down
underneath the image there's going to be
a webinars in courses link this is a
general link that takes you to a page
that summarizes all the different
webinars and courses that we have going
on so right now if you scroll down
you'll see the one that you're watching
right now on july twenty seventh there
are no materials links at the moment but
very soon after this webinar as peter
was indicating this will migrate to the
archived webinars and courses tab which
is up here at the top of the table i'll
go ahead and go there now just to show
you for example like last yesterday
there was another webinar there's a link
over here to materials so that link
materials takes you to our ftp site
where you can download the PowerPoint
PDF of the presentation so that's where
it will be another place if you want to
get to it right now which you can
because it's on the ftp site right now
if i go back up to the very first slide
here although this isn't as fun to copy
down but a CP colon slash slash
dot ly / to the lowercase a q6 lowercase
H uppercase R uppercase R that URL will
take you to the ftp site into the
directory where the slides are i just
sent that link out to the entire
audience and chat i'm not sure what that
looks like on your end but i think you
should see it also eric is there that
page that's not live yet do you know
where that's going to be linked and can
you show them where that will appear so
let me go back to what I'll do is I'm
just going to step through the slides
one more time I think this would be a
little bit easier just because I've
highlighted some things here's the NCBI
homepage where it will be as if you go
down to develop all right so this is
again the page that we have for
developers and API stuff you click that
link what you will see once the page is
live is this page now this page is live
right now but it does not have this ad
the ad up in the upper right about HTTPS
only is not visible currently when the
page goes out later this week this ad
will appear click that and you'll get to
the page that we've been talking about
with all the details on it so the
recording someone else asked about the
recording the recording will be uploaded
and that will pick take depends on how
long it takes stated captioning and
things like that but it should be within
probably a week and a half or something
like that it will be on our YouTube
channel just look for ncbi nlm and
youtube all right so I think what we'll
do at this point is close the webinar we
have some other questions that have come
in to the questions pod will be
addressing those and as we talked about
the beginning of the webinar we will put
answers to those questions up with the
materials so you'll be able to see those
and so if you do have a question that
hasn't been addressed yet please check
back with the materials it will send out
some boat additional information just to
remind you where all of those things are
to all the people who have attended all
right thank you very much and I'll be
signing off
you